yo yo yo
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message it is friday january 28
2022 we are live streaming on rumble
youtube and blaze tv as always do me a
favor subscribe especially to the fine
folks over there at rumble because
something weird is going on with youtube
we all know it we covered it yesterday
so give us a little uh tap of that
notification bell over on rumble and
let's see what happens uh this is a very
big day for me and the entire reuben
report team because finally within the
last hour
the truck with all of our stuff from los
angeles has arrived so i want to put a
disclaimer at the top of the show today
you might hear some screaming you might
hear some yelling you might hear some
banging and moving hopefully not too
much crashing and shattering uh but
there's a whole bunch of people in the
house moving us in and it's a very
exciting time i will not have to sit on
just one ikea chair as i've been doing
for the last week and you guys connor
michael very exciting you're not gonna
have to sit on the floor anymore this is
very exciting you won't have to sit on
the floor and you won't have to sit on
the floor yeah all of our stuff is
coming some of the pieces we've been
missing from the studio will be here i'm
gonna have my own bed again my couch my
blankets and pillows
gonna be able to cook with my stuff
it's all good it's all good so uh anyway
there's a whole bunch of people here so
you might hear a little little banging
and stuff don't worry we're not under
attack as far as i know we got three
stories for you the big thing yesterday
of course is that supreme court justice
stephen breyer is stepping down and he
is going to be
replaced uh well the nominee will be
selected by president joe biden the man
pretending to be president joe biden and
they had a press conference yesterday
and joe
said that whoever he chooses
is going to be a black woman which i'm
pretty sure is pretty much against
everything that the supreme court stands
for and he said it right in front of
briar we've got a whole bunch of video
on that and then of course the
harpies
these crazy people over at the view they
chimed in on it and if you thought the
video that we showed you of whoopi
goldberg talking about covid yesterday
was nuts well just wait till joy behar
chimes in with her brand of her special
brand i should say of progressive racism
when talking about uh one of the other
supreme court justices who happens to be
a black man i think you know who i'm
talking about uh the second story you
know you guys have been asking me for a
couple weeks now last week and a half or
so
to talk about this canadian trucker
situation and i just wanted to get a
little bit more info i wanted to get
some more video i wanted to talk to a
couple people about it and now this
story is really
really breaking through there is what
they are saying is possibly
the world's largest trucker caravan
going across canada right now in protest
of the trudeau government in protest of
these draconian mandates in protest of
all of the endless lockdown lunacy that
has really just wracked canada
in some ways worse than any other
western nation maybe australia maybe
parts of the united states obviously but
canada really has taken a special brand
of this insanity and the people have had
enough and they are stepping up against
uh justin trudeau and the canadian
government and i'm here for him and i
know we have a lot of canadians that
watch the show and i love canada it
sucks that i can't go to canada anymore
because i am unsullied uh but i hope to
get back there one day and i welcome as
many canadians as want to come to the
great state of florida as they would
like so we're gonna talk about that uh
and then finally uh you know we haven't
done too much about bitcoin here but i
thought this was an important story
we've done a little bit i thought this
was an important story that uh the biden
administration is now talking about
regulating bitcoin and it's like man
10 years ago it was like bitcoin is
nothing it's just some fringe thing then
eight years ago it was like oh they're
using it on the dark web then you know
five years ago it was like ah some
people are sort of trading some things
then three years ago oh people can now
use bitcoin to get credit cards to
actually make real purchases and now
it's an enemy of the federal government
so very very interesting stuff oh
and before
we do anything else and guys this is
this is really important we've got some
reuben report breaking news
as you may have heard
uh it's been very chilly here in south
florida for the past week or so
temperatures
possibly dropping below 40 degrees and
there is a warning that has been spread
throughout southern florida i believe we
have a map here
frozen iguanas okay people these frozen
iguanas are possibly going to freeze
while they are in trees they become some
sort of comatose situation and they will
actually fall out of trees and they
could potentially hit you in the head
this happens of course when it dips
below 40 degrees and iguanas could
literally fall out of the sky my god
it's happening right now i can't believe
it iguana's just falling endlessly one
could fall any moment right now you
never up there's another one holy cow
and we're indoors which is even doubly
weird it's just very strange iguanas
could be sliding in they could be
hitting you in any which way oh my god
they're everywhere can you this is
actually an alligator we couldn't get an
iguana that quickly we tried we tried we
went to target this morning we tried to
get iguana this is clyde's alligator uh
michael was kind enough to get clyde
this alligator when we moved in here
because every dog in florida should have
an alligator
so
there's a little we call that comedy bit
for you people hope you enjoyed it there
i'm going to keep the alligator i feel
like maybe there'll be ah there could be
some use for it or you want to throw it
throw it at me at an opportune time
later in the show there you go
all right let's talk about the supreme
court so stephen breyer who is one of
the more liberal members of the supreme
court i would say liberal in the
basically decent sense of the word
liberal which as you know has been
mucked up pretty badly over the last
couple years he's not a crazy leftist
he's sort of a moderate liberal you may
not agree with his positions but i think
for the most part people think he's a
pretty principled guy and we want some
level of balance between liberalism and
conservatism on the supreme court that's
what i would want at least well he has
decided that he's going to step down
he's obviously in his i believe late 70s
we sort of knew that this was coming at
some point there was even a rumor that
he was going to do it during the trump
administration so he waited
long enough so that biden is in charge
so it's a little more of a friendly
right if you're if you're a liberal that
your replacement is most likely going to
be on that side of the aisle or at least
be the guy nominated and then we see
what happens in the senate but as you
can imagine because everyone is insane
this has brought out all of the crazy
people and the partisans to just start
screaming about sexism and racism and
everything else and then there's this
program as you know called the view i
think it's on right now not that any of
you are watching it i think it's on at
11 a.m eastern too so please don't watch
this thing i'm glad you're with me uh
but joy behar who once was alright she
really was i used to see her on the
upper west talk to her and her husband
joy what happened to you
well listen to joy's special brand of
progressive racism you know you
hate that that somebody like amy coney
barrett uh was put in there
because she's a white woman yeah who
they say well she'll go against abortion
rights and she's a woman so that was
deliberate i think clarence thomas a a
black guy a black man a justice okay
i'll give it to him he's a smart guy but
he is to the right of attila the han
this guy and they put him in there
thinking oh a black man will go against
voting rights which is what he does and
it was a terrible and it's a very tricky
business they're pulling over there when
you think about it not to mention the
fact that mitch mcconnell has no concept
of the law when it comes to the supreme
court they know the law they're not
following it right they don't want to
follow now and he's allowed to not
follow terribly disrespectful to appoint
someone like clarence thomas with his
philosophies to the seat of thurgood
marshall a civil rights
all we have to do is start talking about
her and we'll be here yeah we should
talk about that's not today
my god these women are insane and the
view is a program on abc which is one of
the biggest networks
literally in the entire world not just
in america and that is pumped out to
millions mostly housewives
all over the country who are brainwashed
by their drivel so first off it's
interesting because joy says this idea
that amy coney barrett amy comey barrett
was only selected because she's a white
woman well we'll get to joe biden
literally saying he's only going to
select a black female so it's like if
you like identity politics you like it
if you don't like it you don't like it i
don't care if you select a white person
a black person a woman a female a giant
a [ __ ] none of it matters to me do you
know the law will you will you make your
decisions according to the law as a
judge in the highest court of land that
would be me but i am old school uh that
would be me okay uh so first she says
that then she says these crazy things
about clarence thomas i mean he's to the
right of attila the hun and he's a black
man but she's really taking away his
blackness right because she's not
because he's not the right type of black
man for a good white progressive like
joy behar joy behar knows what black men
should think and if you are a black man
who doesn't think what joy behar thinks
you should think you ain't no black man
who is that guy that said you ain't
black if you don't vote for me wasn't
there a guy that did that there was an
elderly man
biden yeah that was joe biden remember
that you ain't black if you don't vote
for me do you see
who the modern racists are there is no
racism out of any mainstream
conservative that could possibly match
the level of racism that comes out of
these people's mouths every single day
in the name of tolerance she does not
like clarence thomas's worldview she
does not like the way he governs so
she's taking away his blackness she by
the way also says that he's taking away
voting rights now notice they never give
you any evidence of that clarence thomas
clarence thomas wants things like you
know you should have an id to vote
people who aren't legally uh citizens of
the united states maybe they shouldn't
be allowed to vote [ __ ] like that okay
but she thinks that that means somehow
he doesn't want black people to vote
these people are racists this is the
same type of pernicious racism that we
saw
during larry elder's campaign for
governor in california where the los
angeles times dared to call him the
black face of white supremacy and old
joe biden showed up the day before the
recall and said without saying larry
elder's name he would not even say the
black man's name
he said that he is a trump clone larry
elder the son of a janitor who grew up
in south central l.a these people are
racists they are racists they are the
new racists and i don't like to play
that game because these words have all
been so mangled and mocked and
everything else but there's no way to
describe it identity politics rots the
brain period i don't care
that it's a woman a man
gay dude
whatever nobody cares except them and we
are we are letting them rot the system
now i thought we'd juxtapose that you
know i love that word we juxtaposed that
with some video of stephen breyer
talking yesterday
about what he believes america is and i
think he'll actually be pleasantly
surprised a country that was dedicated
to
liberty and the proposition that all men
are created equal conceived in liberty
those are his words and dedicated to the
proposition that all men are created
equal and women too
and
we are now engaged in a great civil war
to determine whether that nation
or any nation so conceived and so
dedicated can long endure
see those are the words i want
to see
and experiment
and that's what he thought
it's an experiment and i found some
letters that george washington wrote
where he said the same thing it's an
experiment
that experiment existed then because
even the liberals in europe you know
they're looking over here and they say
it's a great idea in principle but it'll
never work
but we'll show them it does
that's what washington thought
and that's what lincoln thought
and that's what people still think today
and i say oh i want you and i'm talking
to the students now
i say i want you to pick just this up
it's an experiment that's still going on
and i'll tell you something
you know who will see whether that
experiment works
it's you my friend
it's you mr high school student
it's you mr college student that's you
mr law school students it's us but it's
you
it's that next generation and the one
after that
isn't that actually beautiful because
he's right not only is he quoting george
washington but he's quoting the founding
documents he said the word liberty
when's the last time you heard a liberal
say the word liberty which is why i
described him sort of a moderate liberal
not what we think the modern left has
become he's talking about equality we
are all created equal the ongoing
experiment i talk about the experiment
all the time my friend dennis prager has
been talking about the american
experiment the idea that we could govern
ourselves in these different states
decide how we want to do it pick up and
leave if we don't like what's going on
this great experiment in self-governance
it's all here and by the way
that is a
true classical liberal idea but i don't
want to get too lost in all of that so i
thought that that was actually pretty
refreshing because in essence he's
saying hey skin color doesn't matter
gender doesn't matter sexuality doesn't
matter equality under the law matters
now ironically that's very different
than what the guy who is standing behind
him was about to say when he talked
about who he was going to replace
stephen breyer with
the person i will nominate will be
someone with extraordinary
qualifications
character experience and integrity
and that person will be the first black
woman ever nominated to the united
states supreme court
it's long overdue in my view
you know one of the things you can't do
in the united states is higher based on
skin color that's what the civil rights
act is all about okay we've had that for
about 50 plus years that used to be
something that everyone thought was a
good thing that we would be colorblind
when it came to hiring but now at the
highest levels of government the leader
supposed leader of the executive branch
says that i will hire a qualified person
and by the way qualified person that's
great and by the way there are probably
thousands
thousands of qualified black females for
this job
absolutely there's just no doubt about
it right great legal minds no doubt
about it now i may disagree with some of
their legal conclusions or something
like that but there's no doubt the idea
that you would say this is the pool of
people that i am choosing from because
we better have a black woman on there is
actual racism it is the neo-racism that
has been normalized by the left and has
been used by sort of brain-damaged
people like joy behar to convince
average americans that racism is
actually good do you think that dr
martin luther king when he did not want
his children to be judged by the color
of their skin but by the content of
their character would be looking at a
day like yesterday listening to the
president of the united states say hey
we're hiring based on skin color do you
think that's what he wanted or have they
twisted and perverted the very meaning
of the word equality into this twisted
equity thing that has nothing to do with
equality because equity is about
breaking people down equality is about
getting everybody to the same starting
point okay
giving everybody the same uh equality of
opportunity so these people are racists
and i would say to you if you're a
minority watching this whatever that
means to you if you are latino
if you are asian if you are indian
if you are a lesbian if you are trans
why didn't he pick one of you
and if he did would you want him to pick
one of you just on the basis of that but
think about it there are no asian
supreme court justices
asians actually score way better on most
testing we know all the stuff about how
harvard actually discriminates against
asians because too many asians were
getting into harvard that's another type
of neo racism sold us by the left right
so what is really going on here are
these people for minorities or
call me crazy on this one little dave's
gonna go on a little conspiracy theory
right now could it be that the democrats
and the left actually just want black
people as pawns
that they only want them because of
identity politics they want to make sure
through fake gestures like saying ah you
see a certain amount of black people got
oscars and ah you see we have an exactly
proportionate amount of black people on
the supreme court etc etc that black
people will never think oh maybe we
should not vote for these people anymore
these people who institute all of these
policies that destroy our city through
removing police officers that keep us on
the government dole that do all of these
things put us in housing that we can't
get out of because it creates
generational need to basically stay in
the same place all of this stuff do you
think that might be it but we'll go on a
little bit more we've got more videotape
for you at the end joe said
i'm not even going to take questions and
then watch what he does with his mask
thank you all so very very much for
being here and i'm not going to take any
questions because i think it's
inappropriate to take questions uh with
the justice here he's still sitting on
the bench
and uh
uh but you'll have plenty of
opportunities to get me later today and
for the rest of the week next week too
so thank you very much
[Music]
ah the energy the vitality
sense of commandeering the podium by
that guy uh look actually it's not that
big of a deal that he didn't take
questions in this moment yes he could
have he rarely does take questions he
questions he usually just sits there
kind of frozen uh in this instance i
will give him a little bit of a leash on
this because this the justice was right
there so perhaps he didn't want to
politicize it of course that's really
nonsense we all under really understand
that because it's like it's all it's all
politics the funnier part of that really
was just that then he takes the mask
which i believe may have been a backup
mask for briar or maybe it was his mask
it doesn't even matter it just shows you
all of the nonsense he's not wearing a
mask when he talks then he pretends to
put the mask on then he obviously takes
it off when he goes backstage he touches
the mask and then right after if you
watch the video again he touches the
mask he hands it to briar then he
touches his face it's like he's 78 years
old prior is can i get the a john breyer
i'm guessing briars i said late 70s
before he might even be in his early 80s
whatever it might be it's like old guys
touching masks touching faces the same
people who you know two weeks ago briar
was making supreme court decisions
related to osha mandates and whether you
know the government could force you to
get vaccinated and everything else
briar's 83 years old so maybe joe you
don't want to touch the mask and touch
your face and hand it to briar and put
it in his pocket and
all right
let's leave america for a little bit and
talk about canada so i know a lot of you
have wanted me to talk about this story
uh and it and it's really breaking right
now and i hope that i can give it a
little bit of a boost because it's
really important and surprise surprise
it's being completely
ignored by mainstream media and i think
you'll know why by the end of this
so we've got some info here from the
daily wire on what's going on in canada
right now a massive convoy of trucks
currently crossing canada which is
protesting against vaccine mandates for
truckers at the canada u.s border as
well as drivers being forced to wear
masks and trucks may prove to be the
longest truck convoy ever recorded the
truckers hope to make it to ottawa
canada's capital by saturday to stage
their protest if the convoy holds
together it could be 10 times larger
than the world record the sun noted
pointing out that guinness states the
trucks are coming from all over and some
estimates have speculated 10 000 trucks
could compromise
the convoy so the the longest uh convoy
of trucks that's ever happened before
uh was from egypt a couple years ago
this looks like it's going to be much
much bigger than that and actually let's
uh show you some video this is over this
is video of over 50 000 canadian
truckers forming a caravan
wow this is a huge look at they go
forever this is by accident outside of
edmonton heading to calgary january 23rd
2022 convoy
more than trucks lots of borrowers and
trucks
very impressive goes on forever
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is seriously extraordinary stuff
you guys know this canadians aren't
outspoken
when's the last time you were somewhere
and it was like those canadians won't
shut up you know when's the last time a
canadian got into a fight like you have
to push a canadian really far there's
not a lot of them they have a huge
amount of space it's kind of chilly up
there like you know they're usually kind
of funny pleasant people
like they have pushed canadians far
enough 50
000 truckers forming this caravan it's
it's absolutely extraordinary the amount
of people on the roads and it's cold out
there so people out there bringing kids
waving flags uh you know you may
remember that i had maxine bernier on
the show uh probably about two years ago
i think i've had him on a few times
actually and i've done some events with
him up in canada and i toured up in
canada with jordan peterson and you know
a lot of libertarian types were coming
to our events and they were always sold
out and uh maxine bernier runs the
people's party of canada and although
they have not done particularly well in
the elections because canada really has
like an even more entrenched
conservative liberal two-party duopoly
than we do
um it's clear that they have that justin
trudeau and these authoritarian lunatics
they've ignited something they've
ignited the spirit of freedom in canada
and this is good
and speaking of good let's talk about
bad here's canadian prime minister
justin trudeau
we know
the way
through this pandemic
is by getting everyone vaccinated and
the overwhelming majority close to 90 of
canadians have done exactly that
the
small fringe minority
of people who are on their way to ottawa
or who are
holding unacceptable
views uh that they're expressing
do not represent
the views of canadians who have been
there for each other who know
that following the science
and stepping up to protect each other
is the best way to continue to ensure
our freedoms our rights our values as a
country
man what an inauthentic smug
douchebag really
first off this thing where they whisper
while they're telling you briden does
this all the time too you know these
people who are very mean they're and we
are the nice guys like he just like you
know he like kills kittens or something
like he's just absolutely awful uh he
calls this caravan
of 50 000 truckers and all of their
supporters
which never happens in canada nothing
like this they're a fringe minority
right uh he also says that you know
these unvaxed people basically they're
to blame for the pandemic and it's just
like absolute nonsense what this all
started with also was the fact that
these truck drivers just didn't want to
wear masks while they were in their
trucks alone
these people are just absolutely awful i
think we have a little more video from
one of the caravans right
do we have that
13
years old tomorrow and i just wanted to
say best birthday gift ever having you
guys fighting for us i am so glad for
you truckers you rock hi my name is
matthew i'm 12 years old and i'm from
alberta and i just want to say
you guys are awesome keep on trucking
good night truckers thank you
to santa canada truckers
i get a little guy here that wants to
say something to the truckers
[Applause]
thank you checkers
hi my name is
hello i'm talia i'm 10 years old i come
from manitoba i just wanted to thank you
guys
for what you did i'm praying for you i
love you guys hi my name is adrie
and i'm eight years old and i would just
like to say thank you for all you guys
do
small fringe minority small fringe
minority the kids you're listening to
there obviously uh their folks are
having them call in often on cb radio
just to offer guys some support as
they're getting out there these are good
decent freedom loving people these are
not racists these are not people with
fringe views they don't like trudeau
they don't like authoritarianism they
don't like
mandates
and god bless you guys on anything i can
do to help you i am going to do oh and
just to wrap this up i mentioned at the
top of this story it's like why aren't
you seeing this on cnn why aren't you
seeing this on msnbc was this on the
cover of the new york times today
washington post is it on cnn.com right
now michael would you do that for me
real quick
cnn.com right now let's go to the front
page do they have anything on the front
page of cnn.com a very trusted news
source
nothing he's given me a big no now isn't
that interesting isn't that interesting
this huge revolt in canada
much like is happening all over
australia and they don't show you that
mainstream media could it possibly be
could it possibly be that the mainstream
media doesn't want you realizing that
you actually have some power over your
life
that there's other people like you out
there that the jig is almost up
you know don't ban me youtube just
saying what i think all right guys we've
got one more for you i got to do it
somewhat quickly because i am on
outnumbered on fox news at noon we got a
bunch to do in the next hour or so but i
wanted to talk about this bitcoin story
uh we've got a quote here from barons
the bit
administration the biden administration
is preparing to release an executive
action that will task federal agencies
with regulating digital assets such as
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies as a
matter of national security a person
familiar with the white house's plans
tell barons the national security
memorandum expected to come in the next
few weeks would take part would take
parts of the government with anal sorry
would task parts
of the government with analyzing digital
assets and assembling a regulatory
framework that covers cryptos stable
coins and nfts or non-fungible tokens
this person said the state department
treasury department national economic
council and council of economic advisors
would all be involved in the initiative
the white house national security
council would also be involved the
person said since crypto has economic
implications for national security along
those lines the administration would
instruct agencies to work on harmonizing
regulations of digital assets between
countries okay so we've talked a little
bit about bitcoin here actually if you
want to sort of bitcoin 101
i did an interview a few months back
with my friend and one of our locals
investors
alex lloyd who wrote a book he co-wrote
a book called the little bitcoin book i
believe that's the title and you can do
a little more bitcoin 101 but in essence
this idea of a decentralized currency
that no one the fed nor any government
is fully controlling and it is traded
between people okay and then you can
have you know these nfts these digital
assets that you are trading between
people this is the biggest threat that
exists really to the sort of monolithic
one state one world government that
seemingly wants to lock us all in our
rooms have us strapped into vr headsets
and you know offer us a bunch of gruel
to occasionally eat out of as we uh play
whatever the hell it is that we're
playing on uh in the metaverse all day
long uh so this is this is should not be
surprising what i think is interesting
about it the reason i wanted to cover it
was because of the way it has sort of
creeped on us that bitcoin was and
crypto were these fringe things and then
it was like oh okay it's used in the
dark web or people are selling drugs on
it something like that then it starts
getting used then there are these
digital wallets and i've got a little
bit of crypto where you can trade when
it goes up and down you could trade it
like a stock and then you can take some
of your crypto money and you can
actually convert it say into a
mastercard and buy real products and it
was kind of good and then el salvador
said that they are going to start taking
cryptocurrency
and then next thing you know within a
matter of just a couple years it's a
national security threat a national
security threat to the united states and
they're going to try to figure out who's
got bitcoin and how they've got it and
everything else so there is a through
line to today's show from starting with
breyer talking about freedom
then going over to this truck convoy
these people who care about freedom
and then that there is a currency a new
digital currency that is trying to free
the people
i'm gonna keep trying to free the people
i hope you will join me uh guys part two
of my interview with marco rubio senator
from the free state of florida is up on
youtube and rumble right now and of
course the full thing is up already at
reubenreport.locals.com
i am on outnumbered on fox at noon
eastern time and if you want to play
along join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and i'm very
excited because i'm going to be sleeping
in my own bed tonight
do you still have the alligator where's
the alligator you want to throw it at me
one more time there we go
big show big show all right see you
tomorrow no see you monday